The whole universe depends on everything fitting together just right.
Can we choose to be born or we fit into the times we're born into?
And finally, we are pleased to announce...
...that the films selected as the Best Picture nominees for 2012 are:...
What's your name?
Django.
Then you're exactly the one I'm looking for.
We're responsible for these people.
I'm responsible.
007 reporting for duty.
Where the hell have you been?
It's awesome!
I'm looking for someone to share in an adventure.
My mother warned me about getting into cars with strange men.
This isn't a car.
What's your name, rather than Batman?
Lenny.
Let me tell ya, when life reaches out at a moment like this,...
...it's a sin if you don't reach back.
I'm telling you, it's a sin if you don't reach back.